hi I'm time I know everything that has
ever happened and I know everything that
ever will so imagine for a second if I
told you that I knew about something
that's going to happen soon something
that would cause your life to end this
year something that would cause your
life to end this month what if I told
you it was something that would cause
your life to end in one minute what
would you do what would you say
who would you say it to perhaps you
would feel compelled to tell someone you
love or care about that you love and
care about them because you haven't told
them in a long time perhaps you would
want to apologize to someone for
something you did wrong and make things
right before it becomes unresolved
forever perhaps you would try something
you've wanted to experience perhaps you
would take a risk that you've always
wanted to take but have been too scared
to for no good reason now what if I told
you that your life would end that it
wasn't going to be today or this month
or this year that it wasn't going to be
anytime in the immediate future just
sometime in the future would that change
things would you be relieved now would
you no longer feel the need to say or do
the things you wanted to a moment ago if
yes why what is it about knowing that
your life will end but just not knowing
exactly when that makes you feel like
you have all the time in the universe
but you don't need to do or say or be
the things you want to be right now in
life you love just enough time to never
really feel a sense of urgency and doing
the things that matter to you but that
may be a little hard or scary or
inconvenient but not enough time to
realize before it's too late that you
are wrong because one of the seconds
waiting for you in your future will be
your last and there is no escaping this
second when the second arrives it will
catch you off guard and you will not be
able to politely ask me to hold it while
you try to do all the things you wished
you did instead in your prior seconds
and in this second you'll realize that
every second is precious and every
second you have the choice to let the
people you care about know that you care
about them to be kind to others and
leave a pleasant memory in your place to
apologize when you make a mistake to try
your best to choose happiness and
composure to try the things that
fascinate and excite
to share and work towards the things
that you find important to deeply engage
in each second as they pass one by one
tick by tick and to realize that this
second is all there is
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder